[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and the
mind-bending ending of Avengers endgame
has just gotten a whole lot more
confusing with the film now alpha
release on blu-ray in the u.s. many
people have begun asking questions
surrounding a big plot element from the
finale and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down what the screenwriters of
the film have said in regards to it I
just want to get the intro out the way
as quickly as possible so if you're one
of the people who've got dusted during
the snap and haven't had a chance to
watch the film yet then I highly suggest
that you turn off now because yeah there
will be heavy spoilers ahead without the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for clicking this video now let's get
into my breakdown over whether Steve
Rogers is the father of Peggy Carr as
kids okay so the ending of Avengers
endgame deals with a lot of time you why
me wibbly-wobbly stuff with Steve Rogers
traveling back to the past to live out
his life with his long-lost loved agent
Peggy Carter there's been some back and
forth between the writers and directors
both disagreeing with one another
heavily the Russo brothers in a recent
interview that I covered on the channel
said that Steve travelled back in time
and had a life with Peggy Carter which
created an alternate timeline and at the
end of the film he used a Pym particle
to jump back to the bench to see Sam and
Bucky this kind of lines up with the
rules of the film and the paradoxes that
exist within it however in a recent
interview with thr Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely said the following
it was always our intention that he was
the father of those two children there
are time travel loopholes for that it
does introduce the idea that there are
two children who have somewhat
super-soldier DNA so according to them
from the beginning it was always the
intention that Steve Rogers would end up
with Peggy Carter and if he go back and
re-watch the First Avenger
there are clearly seed sown there that
come to fruition and Avengers endgame
where this gets confusing though is that
it directly contradicts what the Russo
brothers have said and at this point the
film almost becomes a kind of
choose-your-own-adventure thing with
there being two possibilities over what
could have
and if this is the case and that means
that Steve Rogers travel back to the
past and hid in the background not
interfering with any of the events as he
knew it would cause more alternate
realities to spring off so yeah Steve
Rogers Captain America pretty much let
9/11 happen and did nothing it adds a
lot more confusion to the timeline and
create its own alternate realities in
our world where we're gonna have people
thinking that Steve didn't cause
alternate timelines and others who think
he did if he didn't it indeed means that
time is cyclical and that what will
happen directly affects the past and
everything is a big loop where the
future changes the past and look I don't
want to bog this video down basically
you need a PhD in theoretical physics to
understand it personally I do actually
align myself more with the side that say
Steve stayed in the past and remained in
the main timeline as I find this ending
sort of ties everything up nicer well we
don't get a version of reality in which
Peggy Carr I didn't get to be with their
long-lost love but I understand why some
people disagree with that way of
thinking it also means that Steve didn't
need to use the quantum tunnel again
which as we know from the film doesn't
happen at least on screen obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this whole
thing do you side with the Russos or the
writers comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the casting news
that Jackie Chan is the discussions to
join the MCU which would be linked at
the end any I got over which character
he's rumored to be playing and their
history so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books then you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
John wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with the chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave it thoughts on this new theory in
the comment section below
the one will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]